foreign
the government is at it again you were
telling me Dave while you were gone
things happened
while I was gone where did that go I
don't know where you were but Jade and I
were hosting the show and I swear I got
1400 people sent me this on Instagram
and there was big headlines on the news
that Biden Administration made big
changes to mortgage rates and the high
credit good credit borrowers were going
to pay the price to allow the riskier
borrowers to get a discount okay so the
rest of your borrowers are getting a
better rate not not at the pay up charge
as much and this is socialized mortgage
so that the the people who did a good
job are going to support the people that
didn't do a good job with a uh by having
a higher rate on the good job people and
a lower rate on the bad job people is
this how it works that sounds about
right so here's the thing sounds like
socialism I'm in yeah okay yes and this
is Progressive there's misinformation
too so the low score folks no they're
still paying more for their mortgages
but the Gap has shrunk okay so to do
that they've increased the rate for the
good score folks they've decreased the
rate for the bad score folks
the punch line is
that the actual rate change
on all of these people
is somewhere around an eighth of a
percent eighth to a quarter is what
we're actually going to see what we're
seeing according to the mortgage
industry okay translation Washington
just announced that they helped all the
poor people
and beat up on the rich people
and once again they did absolutely
nothing
they blew trumpets as if they were going
into battle
and they didn't even have a BB gun it
amounts to about 10 bucks a month per
hundred thousand dollars changed your
life it absolutely changed your life if
you have a low credit score Joe Biden
just changed your life
bullcrap
bullcrap these people this is in the
same bucket of I'm gonna pay off your
student loans when when pray tell old
Joel old Joe when are you going to do
this pray tell
seriously not much time left
I'm old but he makes old a whole new
thing yeah wow
so here's the thing Dave that people
don't understand if you follow the
Ramsay advice which Dave has been
preaching from the mountaintops for 30
years now guess what this doesn't affect
15-year loans which is the only loan
that's who it doesn't affect you because
if you're following us will you tell you
never take out more than a 15-year
mortgage
and never more than a payment of a
Fourth of your take-home pay and always
put down a good down payment and this
program has absolutely no effect on that
at all by the way if you have zero
credit score it doesn't affect you at
all you're going to get the same great
rate you always got which is a premium
rate uh on a zero credit score so if
you're doing the Ramsay stuff uh you
avoided socialism
if you can be mad at the political stuff
all day but financially sleep easy at
night philosophically though you can't
even really be pissed off because he
really didn't do anything it's too much
again too much if you'll pay attention
to the actual dollars that these
programs that are supposed to save you
coming from Washington create the actual
dollars
then you will realize that these people
talk like they are doing something and
they never do anything and that's true
of the Republicans too by the way so I
mean if you live in Washington your goal
is to make a big deal out of nothing and
act like you did something so that we
all go oh I love them I'm going to vote
for them again they took care of me you
know one of the worst hate I got and I
still think there's a Reddit entire
Reddit thread on hating Dave Ramsey on
this was remember when uh Trump came out
with the uh covet bucks and then Biden
we had Biden bucks also in the both of
them did it uh and they and they one of
them I can't remember which one was said
they gave out thirteen hundred dollars
you're gonna everybody's gonna get
thirteen hundred dollars and I was on
Fox News and I said if 1300 changes your
life you really don't have a life
listen if thirteen hundred dollars
changes your life you don't have a life
honestly you're gonna get canceled again
Dave what are you trying to do here I
mean it might feed you this week it
might pay your light bill for a week but
at the end of the month you're still
screwed
if you if if you go wow I got the lot oh
God quick Buy my house my house I got
1300 bucks you know I mean is that just
a dumber and crap it's a it's a very
temporary Band-Aid on a bigger problem
it lasts about a minute and a half
and so truly if mathematically it's not
a philosophical statement it's not an
old Rich Boomer doesn't understand you
stupid butt people seriously that's just
dumb okay thirteen hundred dollars
mathematically doesn't change your life
a quarter of a percent an eighth of a
percent change in your mortgage one way
or the other does not change your life
and if you're being wise in the way
you're taking out a mortgage or you're
not taking out a mortgage at all guess
how much it affected my interest rate
zero
zero I am immune to socialism wow
because I don't borrow money you don't
play the game of the system and you
don't have to win the stupid prizes of
the system amazing how that works wow
I'm serious this is but I
yeah yeah I mean we announced when you
know when we announced um that we were
going to forgive student loans right
when we before election
and then promptly did nothing for a year
and a half a year and eight months but
in August prior to the midterms an
executive order is issued to forgive the
student loans that's Us timing as the
case and it says
no doubt that was sussy it was very
sassy
they dangle the carrot to try to get the
vote and they do nothing and they and
here's the thing people call us and they
say well Dave why would I pay off my
loans why would I the government because
it's only ten thousand dollars and oh by
the way have you noticed it has never
freaking happened
did you notice that part
did you notice that it's like I promised
it's a political promise how how old do
you have to be before you understand
this is not going to happen
I mean what
we need it we need to we need we need to
distribute little vials of cynicism to
this generation and let them become
cynical about Washington like the old
people have and because we are suspect
of everything they do there because it
is all for show and not for doe
I mean it doesn't change your life I've
been doing this a long time I've been
for 30 years I've been coaching America
on how to build wealth and for 30 I
still am waiting on Washington to change
my life
I get up every morning I say Lord
Lord Jesus when is Washington going to
change my life does he even answer that
one no he's not he's like he's getting
better he's still laughing he's just it
is a trick even if it's a promise or
it's something that actually happens
like this mortgage situation it's not
changing your life well so if it's all
over the news and you know fox has acted
like it's a socialist conspiracy coming
out of the way it's a good talking point
well they're trying to you know burn
down the White House because Biden
changed the mortgage thing with a stroke
of a pen it really changes it's like 10
bucks and everybody that gets a 15-year
mortgage it doesn't apply to you and so
you know it's it's it's irrelevant
it didn't once again hot air no
substance you know that's just it's just
full it's like a Chinese spa balloon I
mean it's just hot air no substitution
right down it's just more crap well and
it's more reason to follow the Ramsay
plan because if you follow it you don't
have to worry about the one what the
next headline is going to be in the next
mortgage rate you just sleep better at
night going all right I'm gonna get a
15-year loan pay it off and then by the
way sleep doesn't get rid of fouchy
either so I mean it's not like he's a
savior okay so you can be mad at me if
you're a lefty or a righty or whatever
just all of you get in line right but
the bottom line is if you're waiting on
the White House to fix your life let me
give you a hint the secret is not in the
White House the secret is in your house
get yourself a mirror look in the mirror
and go you the problem
and you the solution because that's
where your help is going to come from
boys and girls it's not coming from the
Island of Misfit Toys